optimism I'm gonna be on a snapchat
optimism kick I'm sorry it just hit me
optimism [ __ ] selling optimism it's
the optimism unicorn it's the optimism
unicorn d-roc have you ever seen one
before it's rare
thank you you'd be masking questions
resto yeah yeah I'd show you something
real quick oh my gosh whenever you're
the little wheel roller all right oh my
god I also card and it's gonna close out
so I want for like a wheelchair like
stopwatch things like you or anything
like go do like you want because if you
want something you don't have that much
time yeah yes hey good how are you
[Music]
I think I [ __ ] it to me I got I was
come to a fight or you know maybe maybe
as I get older I'm starting to real
something with the eyes I get older I'm
sort of realizing more like your kind of
thing you know I'm thinking about
putting I think I'm at I'm thinking
about putting a Facebook post of the
video and the entire article in like one
post like the video company with the
long-form text I want to try that being
in there for some reason you guys want
that but like I want way more like pro
and con reactions like the first one's
perfect
it's perfect that's the kind of stuff
you know I want I want more of like
marketing talk and referencing marketing
is not interesting and the other thing
we can do just says the strategy is they
mention the brand but we go back 5 or 10
tweets and we find out they're trying to
make the basketball team right and we
get like the surprise them and help them
practice I'm a big believer that a name
is nothing until you make it
nobody knew what Google or Facebook or
you know Nike meant until it was made
this campaign is gonna be meaningful to
their business because of how we execute
more so than the hashtag or the theme
you know what I mean and they're both
great and they're both great to me to me
to me actually I just want to give
everybody context of how I roll if I get
more involved and stuff like this is I'm
more than the know business than the yes
business you know what I mean for me if
something just so insane and I'm like
what the hell like I'm just you know and
I said I'm crazy so that's never gonna
happen
because it's difficult for people to
wrap their head around it after you've
been branded in their mind so I think it
requires enormous amounts of humility
and patience for the person that's going
through it and I will give you one other
thing and I think this is probably the
crux of the article for me if I was
reading it
the biggest problem is people trying to
rebrand themselves in something that are
not good at or capable of doing like I'd
love to be a rapper
I'd love to rebrand myself a rapper I
was actually a marketing and business
guy which is why it was easy for me to
transition from a wine personality but
if I try next week to position myself as
a hip-hop artist I've got a problem and
I think I'm I think I'm seeing a lot of
people try to reposition themselves as
entrepreneurs or as thought leaders in
certain genres when they are actually
not that you know I'm feeling it a lot
because of entrepreneurship everybody
wants to be an entrepreneur even though
they never sold anything in the goddamn
lives so so and now that doesn't mean
you can't be but before you start
branding I think there's a very distinct
thing I'm about to tell you I would
rebrand myself as somebody who's going
through the journey of becoming an
entrepreneur versus branding myself as
an entrepreneur got it and I think
that's the powerful distinction I think
people are faking the funk I think
people are way too bought into faking
until you make it faking until you make
it worked when nobody was watching
something I don't think I talked a lot
about with you guys about this whole
fake it to make it thing which I think
was a really good strategy for a long
period of time the problem right now is
some of you were faking it in public
fake it till you make it was great
because nobody was watching and you were
faking it by doing it you were learning
you were learning on the job it is
probably the more noble way to say it
the problem is so many of you now are
saying you're there before you're there
we encountered that yesterday and in
Denver lovely kid just that you know so
why might not make any money you're not
selling anything like you know that's
its most basic form of entrepreneurship
you're just not there yet and you may
get there so so I think it's super
important for people to start
understanding what's really happening in
the ecosystem which is you know so many
of you are projecting a personality and
social and it just really matters that
there's something behind it and and
that's kind of personal brands is what
we were talking about there so please
you know that little distinction and
replay it right now d-roc I want you to
do the Roberta's like so many of you
projecting a personality and social
and it just really matters if there's
something behind it there's a
distinction between you know there's a
very big distinction between I'm going
through the journey of becoming this and
I am this and way too many of you were
saying I am this and nobody believes you
how the cam has to meet you such a
pleasure
how are you coming I'm good thanks for
having me as your day good cool how's it
going it's good yeah so who's in the
crowd bruising the crowd so it is about
20% Enterprise 40% mid-market and the
rest is SMB on selling mainly b2b mainly
chief like 19 Evert 90% right you take
your brothers what's your name
Peter Peter crane beat you man nice to
meet you yeah thank you thank you so
much my point of view on how to use all
the new tools that I'm good at from a
b2b sales point of view
introducing you wait brother that's your
play nice to meet you how are you doing
it yeah I'm thrilled to be here it's
great stuff thank you man
sales people easy you give him a target
they Roberto you can make their actions
right right right I'm just curious what
people are actually doing are they cold
emailing or they're just linking up with
everybody on LinkedIn and hoping are
they yeah
are you tell our guys that all the time
like still pre shut if you sit sudden
your buddy that email does respond to it
you are not responding to it and then
speak you mean you mean the cold email
that has that that it's like I am yeah
hi Gary may I speak to you for a minute
that's not how you speak to someone like
I oh I know where to go thank you thank
you thank you Adam
and the truth is and I know those four
very well frederick i think is a
purebred salesman um but I really do
think that I was born very lucky and
that I think my parents are very
opposite and I think I feel very in key
kinship with my marketing and with my
sales and so that's what I want to focus
on because I think a lot of people here
could make a lot more money if they
eliminated two things one laziness to be
very frank and and two idealistic points
of view of how they've made their money
in the past I think one of the biggest
concerns I have sitting here in a world
where I'm hungry to get one to two
people three people to get a lot of
value out of this talk is the way you
made your money before is my enemy the
way you've been successful yesterday is
my enemy it is stunning
if you understood what runs through my
head every morning on how little I think
anybody should give a [ __ ] about
anything I achieved yesterday back the
biggest problem is people get to the
reason I've been successful on the
boards in NGO and you know of my work is
because I've brought business DNA to the
nonprofit sector like let's eliminate
the romance don't tell me the fluff tell
me that I'm gonna save 17,000 dollars a
year by giving you 25,000 and I'll write
you 50,000 got it you're welcome thank
you guys
hi guys look what look here's the thing
yeah I know I've been in business
development yes
but I have more balls and desire to tear
up time do me a favor it's time to give
him that bad get me get me give me 25
minutes at the office let me let me be
the real thoughts oh that was awesome
thank you I don't I think I might get
fired in my ass list how many you don't
have to sacrifice for hustle you have to
sacrifice any Tyler seasons of house of
cards you have to sacrifice candy crush
you have to sacrifice being on the
bowling and dart and softball team if
you want big results headed to Cleveland
for the game it should be a lot of fun
little networking business action I'll
be fun really good day this was a great
conference I just spoke at sales machine
16 really good job guys seriously really
good stuff great crowd sales you know I
took so much about marketing and
branding that I missed the sales card so
it's fun to kind of dust up some of
those chops good day had some really
intense solid meetings today got some
really good stuff done Misha's school
had a graduation so I've seen a little
family time so a nice little uh
this little kind of family branding and
running a business day
[Music]
[Music]